c'est l'heure de notre second débat je
vous propose de revenir sur la décision
du Conseil constitutionnel du 14 avril
dernier les 9 sages vous le savez valide
ce jour-là l'essentiel de la réforme des
retraites et voit s'abattre également
sur eux plusieurs critiques cette
polémique est-elle justifiée faut-il
réformer cette instance former de
personnalités nommées par les présidents
de la République de l'Assemblée
nationale et du Sénat avant de débattre
retour sur cette décision rendue dans un
climat pesant avec Adrien
une image qui restera dans les annales
le 14 février dernier le conseiller
constitutionnel retranché derrière des
cordons de force de l'ordre valide
l'essentiel de la réforme des retraites
en réaction des milliers de personnes
ont protesté dans les rues certains
manifestants dénoncent une décision
politique le conseil institutionnel ne
peut pas valoir plus que la Constitution
qu'il défend pour les opposants à la
réforme il y avait pourtant matière à
sanctionner la stratégie du gouvernement
notamment le choix de l'article 47.1 de
la Constitution pour réduire le temps
des débats parlementaires ou encore le
recours au 49-3 pour imposer une
adoption sans vote
a ouvert une nouvelle porte en faveur de
l'exécutive visant à faire passer des
réformes en utilisant le moins possible
les débats parlementaires depuis sa
création en 1958 pourtant le Conseil n'a
censuré totalement un texte qu'à 17
reprises pour l'historien Jean garrigue
sa décision sur la réforme des retraites
n'est donc pas partisane et il y a en
réalité une un fil conducteur juridique
et c'est très compliqué de dire que tel
ou tel camp politique est lésé par les
décisions du Conseil constitutionnel
l'actuel président du Conseil
constitutionnel n'a pas été désigné par
le Président de la République actuelle
donc là l'intervention la pression
politique n'est pas systématique
l'épisode de leur réforme des retraites
a relancé le débat autour du mode de
nomination des sages et 9 membres du
conseil sont nommés par le chef de
l'État et les présidents des deux
assemblées ce qui pose problème selon
certains juristes il n'y a aucun critère
de compétence dans la nomination des
membres il n'y a aucun critère d'âge il
n'y a aucun critère de diversité le
Conseil consuel peut se retrouver assez
monocolor en réalité dans ces opinions
politiques dans sa représentation
de la population l'institution a
toutefois évolué ces dernières années
les anciens présidents de la République
peuvent être membres à vie mais aucun
des sièges actuellement et depuis 2008
chaque citoyen peut saisir le Conseil
tout cela va finalement dans le sens
d'une forme de démocratisation de
l'institution mais on peut aller plus
loin à travers une désignation qui fasse
beaucoup plus sa part aux collectif aux
collectif des parlementaires par exemple
pour changer le mode de nomination des
sages une révision de la Constitution
serait nécessaire faut-il réformer le
Conseil constitutionnel est-il impartial
voilà le thème de notre débat et
j'accueille Noël Lenoir bonsoir
bienvenue membre noire du Conseil
constitutionnel ancienne ministre des
affaires européennes c'était lors du
second mandat de Jacques Chirac et
potier bonsoir bienvenue à vous aussi
vous êtes expert associés à la Fondation
Jean Jaurès Laurine fontaine bonsoir
bienvenue vous êtes professeur de droit
public et constitutionnel et vous
publiez ce livre la Constitution
maltraité anatomie du Conseil
constitutionnel Mathieu croissanto
évidemment est resté à mes côtés je
reviens à cette décision du 14 avril qui
se déroulent on s'en souvient dans un
dans un climat particulier lourd
notamment vous souvenez sûrement de
cette photo de CRS déployée devant le
Conseil constitutionnel qui était à la
une de nos quotidien de nos confrères du
quotidien Libération Noël Lenoir vous
avez siéger au conseil pensionnel de 92
à 2001 est-ce que vous avez souvenir de
décision à ce point sous pression
non bien entendu j'ai jamais eu
l'occasion de constater des
manifestations mais celle-ci m'a pas du
tout étonné puisque on est dans un
contexte de stratégie du chaos de
certains partis politiques et de
certains syndicats
en dépit de l'unité syndicale donc ce
climat m'a pas du tout choqué la
décision qui a été disons la plus
controversée lorsque j'y étais c'était
la décision que nous avons prise en 93
sur une loi immigration ou le Conseil a
donné une interprétation très extensive
du droit d'asile qui recouvrait un peu
un droit d'asile économique et donc le
constituant a eu le dernier mot puisque
il y a eu un changement de la
Constitution mais c'est la seule fois
pendant toutes ces années c'est 9 années
où j'ai constaté cela mais je dois dire
que ça renvoie tout à fait au climat
d'assemblée moi j'ai été administrateur
au Sénat pendant 10 ans je n'ai jamais
vu des comportements tels que ceux
auxquels on assiste aujourd'hui dans une
enceinte parlementaire
jamais donc en réalité c'est un contexte
social les politiques tout à fait
particuliers qui ressemble un peu à la
République de weimark j'espère que ça ne
débouchera pas sur la même chose en 1933
une démocratie doit défendre sa
juridiction suprême avec avec force CRS
est-ce que c'est un signe de maladie de
maladie de démocratie on a une
démocratie française qui globalement ne
va pas très bien on a une brutalisation
des rapports politiques des rapports
sociaux des échanges dans les médias
donc cette manifestation à la n'était
aussi un des symptômes néanmoins on peut
dire que le maintien de l'ordre a été
relativement aisé il y a pas eu de
débordement énorme il n'y a pas eu de
siège devant le conséquence d'une
certaine façon c'est une démonstration
de force pour éviter tout débordement
bon
moi ça m'a pas semblé quelque chose
d'absolument extraordinaire on n'était
pas du tout dans les mêmes images ou les
mêmes risques que
l'envahissement du Capitole ou
l'envahissement de la capitale du Brésil
on était à mon avis dans quelque chose
beaucoup plus mesuré et plutôt
présentifs j'en viens à la lune des
premières questions qui est un peu
centrale dans ce débat sur le
l'impartialité du Conseil
constitutionnel learning fontaine et on
démarre sur cette décision du 14 avril
je rappelle qu'elle valide on va dire
l'essentiel de la réforme des retraites
pour vous elle était quoi il est
équilibrée partisane comment vous la
définissez cette décision
la première chose que j'ai soulignée
quand j'ai commenté cette décision c'est
que effectivement on peut dire que elle
a été rendue contrairement aux
apparences nécessaires de l'impartialité
qui est normalement un principe qui doit
guider la justice alors qu'est-ce que ça
signifie ça signifie que lorsque des
personnes qui vont juger qui vont
délibérer et bien objectivement un
conflit d'intérêt avec ce qu'il juge et
bien la pratique nécessaire dans un état
de droit démocratique c'est qu'il se
déporte or ici dans cette décision nous
avions deux personnes qui pouvaient être
dit avoir un conflit objectif avec la
loi qui est jugée puisque l'une avait
déjà porté défendu en tout cas le
premier projet de réforme des retraites
sous la présidence d'Emmanuel Macron
Jacqueline Gouraud et Alain Juppé de son
côté avait lui porter et fait adopter
une réforme des retraites qui avait
aussi entraîné un conflit populaire très
fort et ça il n'était pas juge à cette
époque là et donc ça les place dans une
situation sont très particuliers à
vis-à-vis de ce qu'il juge et la
pratique des autres cours suprêmes est
constitutionnel et l'étranger c'est de
se déporter dans cette hypothèse là
il n'aurait pas dû participer au
délibérer parce que ça jette un doute
légitime sur les décisions qui sont
rendus ça c'est la première chose alors
je vous laisserai dérouler après et je
vous redonnerai évidemment la parole
mais je veux bien parce que je pense que
tout le monde n'est pas d'accord autour
de de cette table sur ce premier point
est-ce que Alain Juppé Jacqueline gros
aurait dû se déporter conflit d'intérêt
ou pas qu'est-ce que vous dites là
dessus Noël le noir je pense que compte
tenu de la composition du conseil qui
est singulière qui n'est pas plus
politisée que dans les autres cours
constitutionnels si on voit la Cour
suprême des États-Unis elle est
infiniment plus politiqueisée que la
nôtre puisque les juges sont interrogés
sur les votes futures qu'il prendront au
sein de la cour sur l'avortement et sur
des problèmes sociétaux très graves
quant à la cour allemande il faut avoir
sa carte du parti puisque ce sont les
parties qui proposent les juges et donc
il y a des juges de gauche et il y a des
juges de droite le Conseil effectivement
n'avait pas été prévu pour être une cour
en 58 c'est devenu une cour ce qui est
d'ailleurs assez remarquable et donc ce
qui est mis en cause là c'est pas
l'impartialité c'est le fait que le
vivier
dénominations soit parfois politique
mais moi je prends un seul exemple et
j'en finirai là Laurent Fabius lorsqu'il
était au groupe socialiste à chaque fois
qu'il y a une réforme des retraites
évidemment sauf sous Mitterrand qui 65 à
60 ans l'âge de la retraite et bien il
faisait partie des parlementaires qui
contestaient devant le Conseil
constitutionnel la réforme des retraites
et je ne connais pas le secret des votes
mais je pense pas qu'il est voté contre
la décision qu'on parle au conseil donc
cette année
en tant que politique il a pris une
position en tant que juge
constitutionnel il a peut-être ou
peut-être ou très probablement pris une
position contraire et je crois que c'est
un bon exemple j'ai une question parce
que si on vous suit il faut pas nommer
de d'anciens Premier ministre parce
qu'ils ont eu apporter tout un tas de
réforme dans tout un tas de secteurs ni
même ni même dans sa ministre puisque
Jacqueline gros où il fait de porter la
forme de retraite dont elle n'était pas
en charge mais parce que elle était
collègue ou membre donc faut arrêter de
nommer les anciens membres de
gouvernement ou de productivités
exactement la problématique du Conseil
constitutionnel aujourd'hui c'est qu'il
est composé presque exclusivement des
personnalités qui ont une longue
carrière politique derrière elle c'est
où qui ont des liens avec l'exercice du
pouvoir politique qu'ils doivent juger
donc ça ça met le Conseil
constitutionnel dans une situation
structurelle de juge et partie donc
c'est une véritable problématique en
effet il faudrait commencer par ne pas
nommer des personnes qui ont cette
carrière-là
de cabinet puisque ce sont deux
fonctions non pas du tout c'est
absolument pas ce que je défends pour le
coup
ce que je défends c'est d'abord l'idée
qui ne doit pas y avoir de personnalités
politiques ou liées à l'exercice du
pouvoir ensuite il appartient au corps
politique et social de faire un choix
des juristes peut-être mais évidemment
pas que ça me semble absolument
nécessaire mais en tout cas pas de
personnalité qui sont en fait jugés
partie alors je voudrais la parole sur
votre deuxième point tout à l'heure je
ne l'oublie pas de vous en faites pas
mais sur cette question puisqu'on y est
je vous propose d'entendre la réaction
d'un jury spécialiste de droit
constitutionnel c'est Bertrand Mathieu
en est en plein sur ce débat mode de
nomination ministre pas ministre
politique pas politique écoutez il y a
aucun mode de nomination qui n'est
parfait dans beaucoup de des pays les
membres du Conseil constitutionnel sont
nommés par le Parlement c'est encore
plus politisé ce qui peut poser problème
c'est qu'en sont nommé au Conseil
constitutionnel des personnalités qui
viennent d'exercer immédiatement
auparavant une fonction politique par
exemple de ministre
votre avis là-dessus est-ce qu'il faut
je sais pas un temps de latence
interdire au ministre de d'intégrer le
Conseil constitutionnel je sais pas un
an deux ans trois ans après leur et
encore là-dessus votre argument c'est
Alain Juppé vous rendez compte ça fait
30 ans
donc là je pense effectivement il y a un
temps de la danse qui fait que
difficilement faire le rapprochement
entre les deux alors après Alain Juppé a
des convictions quand il a été nommé au
président à la présidente du Conseil
constitutionnel bien sûr mais je pense
que à partir du moment où on fait ce
choix de nommer des personnalités elles
auront eu forcément à connaître des
questions donc moi je pense que la
question qui se pose c'est
l'élargissement de la composition du
conseil fonctionnel
probablement être aussi des critères de
compétences et je dirais qu'on aurait
peut-être besoin d'une composition
peut-être plus équilibrée avoir que des
politiques c'est un problème avoir que
des personnalités qui ne connaîtraient
rien la politique qui ne serait que des
techniciens du droit ou des citoyens je
pense que ça serait pas forcément une
bonne chose non plus alors ça c'était
votre premier point le second si vous
parlez d'un partialité structurelle oui
c'est ce qu'on disait tout à l'heure
c'est à nommé à le composer de cette
manière là le Conseil immanquablement se
retrouve toujours dans cette situation
mais le résultat le résultat c'est que
en fait il y a une sensibilité extrême
des membres du Conseil constitutionnel à
la chose politique et ce qui fonde les
politiques publiques et ça se ça se voit
dans les décisions ou en fait le conseil
ne fait pas véritablement son travail un
travail de réflexion autour de la
Constitution il n'argument d'ailleurs
pas du tout ces décisions et le résultat
dans cette décision du 14 avril et est
assez est assez épatant et je pense
qu'il franchit d'ailleurs un pas
supplémentaire dans son absence de
réflexion autour de la question
constitutionnelle parce qu'en effet il
est amené à valider selon une logique
qui
est tout à fait étrangère je pense à
l'idée même de constitution et bien la
pratique ici du gouvernement parce que
c'est une pratique inédite vous madame
le noir parlait de pratiques inédites au
sein du Parlement mais il faut rappeler
que la pratique gouvernementale depuis
le mois de janvier est aussi inédite on
utilise un projet de loi de financement
de la sécurité etc
parce que
l'idée de constitution
originellement c'est l'idée de limite
limite à l'exercice du pouvoir pour
qu'il n'y ait pas un pouvoir arbitraire
et ces limites là elles doivent être
opposées aux politiques à partir du
moment où elles ont été décidées dans la
Constitution alors je vous interromps et
je vous donne la parole de Noël non
parce que je vous vois en réaction à ses
propos et pas du tout d'accord non alors
bon première j'ai une toute petite
remarque générale je ne pense pas que ce
soit un bon service rendu aux étudiants
que de systématiquement décrédibiliser
les institutions politiques en ce moment
je le dis à l'âge que j'ai qui est
beaucoup plus important que le vôtre
quand j'ai été nommé au conseil avec 41
ans et donc j'étais un peu pétroleuse
c'est tout à fait normal je pense qu'on
est vraiment sur le fil du rasoir et je
suis très étonnée en lisante
quotidiennement les revues juridiques de
voir combien les professeurs de droit en
grande majorité
décrédibilise les institutions il y a
une espèce de frustration qui me paraît
un peu dangereuse
sur la décision du Conseil
constitutionnel dont vous avez beaucoup
parlé et donc je ne veux pas revenir
j'en ai aussi fait le commentaire je
suis quand même frappée de voir qu'il y
avait pratiquement pas chez les
requérants de critiques de la réforme au
fond et d'ailleurs les régimes spéciaux
même monsieur Mélenchon n'en a pas parlé
même Madame Le Pen n'en a pas parlé
puisque c'était les deux partis
politiques qui ont effectué qui ont fait
le recours au Conseil ce n'était que des
questions de procédure que des questions
de procédure moi ça m'intéresse pas
beaucoup la procédure on a beaucoup
discuté du 47,3 je quand même
rappellerai que le 47,3 il est issu de
propositions de Jaurès et de Bloom et de
guimolay pourquoi parce que nous sommes
dans un contexte en France ou le vrai
handicap de cette pays c'est de toujours
changer c'est-à-dire il y a pas un parti
politique qui subsiste dans le temps
toutes les autres grandes démocraties
ont des politique qui existe depuis des
décennies nous il y a plus un seul parti
politique qui existe
avant la guerre après la guerre et même
plus récemment ça bouge tout le temps et
donc le règlement des assemblées qui
n'est d'ailleurs pas plus sévère que
d'autres réglement des assemblées et la
Constitution on reflété ce problème
chronique de l'instabilité ministérielle
et le Conseil constitutionnel pour moi
ne pouvait pas décider autrement que de
se conformer au règlement du Sénat et à
la constitution suivant une
jurisprudence qui date de 1990 alors
vous ouvrez un thème que je trouve
passionnant est-ce que finalement est-ce
qu'il faut en ce moment critiquer le
Conseil conditionnel remettre en
question son fonctionnement ou pas alors
je vous propose d'abord critique
dangereux
et ça ouvre on est en plein dans un des
chapitres qu'on avait prévu dans ce
débat donc ça tombe très bien on va
l'évoquer d'abord en donnant la parole
tiens à Laurent Berger on est lors de la
journée de mobilisation qui précède la
décision du Conseil constitutionnel et
Laurent Berger le secrétaire général de
la CFDT nous dit qu'il va respecter les
règles
non je vais être clair là-dessus on peut
pas on peut pas dans notre démocratie
craindre une crise démocratique craint
d'une dérive démocratique et ne pas
respecter les institutions qui sont
notre cadre commun moi quand je faisais
du foot quand je rentrais sur le terrain
il y avait des règles du jeu toutes me
plaisaient pas forcément mais si je
perdais c'est parce que c'est souvent
pas à cause des règles du jeu donc voilà
pour la réaction de Laurent Berger il
respecte la décision par avance la
décision des Nauges contrairement à
Jean-Luc Mélenchon alors lui ils sont à
prendre directement au Conseil
constitutionnel oui et il a été un des
rares à le faire dès le soir de la
décision sur la réforme des retraites
dans un tweet d'abord la décision du
Conseil constitutionnel montre qu'il est
plus attentif aux besoins de la
monarchie présidentielle qu'elle se du
peuple dit Jean-Luc Mélenchon en gros
une critique en deux temps à la fois sur
sa fonction celle qu'on a un chien de
garde de l'exécutif
Michel Debré mais aussi sur sa
déconnexion supposée avec le peuple ou
les aspirations populaires et puis il en
a remis une deuxième dose face caméra
avant le départ des du cortège parisien
c'était lors de la manifestation du 1er
mai regardez
Constitution traditionnel ne peut pas
valoir plus que la Constitution qu'il
défend il n'y a pas de bons conseils
constitutionnel aussi longtemps qu'il y
a une mauvaise constitution voilà et
puis la prononcé cette petite phrase la
mauvaise République la mauvaise ça
allait jusque-là et c'était quand même
important de le rappeler elle sera qu'un
homme politique s'en prenne ainsi au
Conseil constitutionnel alors j'ai dit
en commençant qu'il avait été l'un des
rares à le faire cette fois-ci ce qui
est vrai même en rassemblement national
qui est tout à sa quête de
respectabilité Marine Le Pen s'est tout
juste autorisé à s'interroger sur le
mode de désignation le mode de
nomination des Desages mais en ajoutant
aussitôt qu'elle respecterait la
décision donc c'est rare aujourd'hui du
oui est-ce que c'est rare par le passé
non on se souvient je me suis souvenu
des décrits d'orfray poussés par
certains sarkozymes au moment où le
Conseil constitutionnel avait pris la
décision de ne pas valider enfin de
configurer la décision de ne pas valider
les comptes de campagne de Nicolas
Sarkozy à l'époque ils accusaient
Jean-Louis Debré supposé être chiracquin
d'avoir voulu se payer Sarko ou alors
Brice Hortefeux lui qui disait comment
ne pas s'interroger sur la décision de
cette institution après la nomination
récente de trois conseillers par le
pouvoir lui il voyait plutôt la main des
des socialistes je suis souvenu Patrick
de vegian quand il était ministre disait
le Conseil constitutionnel c'est pas une
vache sacrée on peut le critiquer ou à
l'autre bout de l'échiquier politique la
présidente du groupe communiste au Sénat
Éliane Assassi qui jugeait que le
Conseil constitutionnel avait fait un
choix de classe indigne quand c'était
quand le Conseil constitutionnel avait
annulé la fameuse taxe à 75% s'en
souvient pas François Hollande
importante avec Jean-Luc Mélenchon c'est
que ce celles et ceux que vous venez
citer ne veulent pas changer de
République oui et car la critique
ponctuelle qu'on a entendu là de conseil
constitutionnel par Jean-Luc Mélenchon
s'inscrit dans un plus vaste dessin on
le sait Jean-Luc Mélenchon jusque la
Cinquième République est à bout de
souffle et qu'il est temps de la
remplacer par une sixième république et
depuis la réélection d'Emmanuel Macron
les insoumises sont lancés dans une
remise en cause une certaine façon si
systématique du jeu institutionnel ça a
commencé par le président et mal élu il
est élu il est pas élu non il vous
souvenez ensuite ça a suivi au
législatives l'absence de majorité
absolue c'est devenu une minorité les
insoumises
pas la majoritaire relative il appelait
la minorité on a eu ensuite
cet outil la commission mixte paritaire
vous vous souvenez était jugé comme une
chambre noire désignée comme une chambre
noire ça se fait dans votre dos ça
devrait se faire sous les projecteurs et
sous les caméras et donc là on voit le
Conseil constitutionnel en gros on voit
bien c'est
critiqueront les uns sapés et on les
autres décrédibiliser on peut même
ajouter un à un tous les leviers
institutionnels pour de cette république
là pour montrer la nécessité de passer à
autre chose à la suivante on comprend
bien l'idée j'allais dire mais de cette
technique mais on en comprend bien aussi
les dangers votre avis je vous donne la
parole juste après mais votre avis sur
alors je vais revenir à la finalement la
critique de conseil constitutionnel
cette question parce que nous on la pose
là est-ce qu'il faut réformer est-ce que
c'est dangereux moi je pense que c'est
dangereux parce que c'est une remise en
cause finalement de l'État de droit ou
des démocratique et donc à vouloir
systématiquement critiquer toutes les
institutions dans leur soubassement
démocratique même moi je trouve ça
dangereux on peut dire qu'on est en
faveur d'une réforme du Conseil consuel
on peut pointer un certain nombre
d'insuffisance bien sûr mais l'attaque
que fait Jean-Luc Mélenchon de manière
très frontale moi je la trouve
dangereuse le noir et ensuite je vous
donne la parole alors une petite
réflexion je trouve que Jean-Luc
Mélenchon aurait dû changer de veste
parce que une veste comme ça en cuir
noir moi ça m'a fait peur mais enfin
c'est une petite réflexion personnelle
surtout pour tenir ce genre de propos
alors pour être un petit peu plus disons
conciliante avec Jean-Luc Mélenchon je
me souviens et je le dis tout à fait
sans acrimonie puisque je lui dois ma
carrière de François Mitterrand et du
coup d'état permanent François
Mitterrand avait critiqué le général de
Gaulle pendant 23 ans donc il avait
quand même un petit peu de de constance
dans ses idées il avait écrit un livre
en disant que c'était la Dict ature que
c'était le coup d'état permanent et puis
quand il a exercé le pouvoir et je l'ai
connu de très près bah il était presque
aussi monarchique sinon davantage que
son prédécesseur donc je pense que ça
c'est vraiment de la politique
politicienne
cette fois-ci ça ne marchera pas pour
Mélenchon mais c'est vrai que il monte
d'un cran à chaque fois dans la critique
des institutions dans la critique de la
République et il pense que ça va
remonter les foules mais ça ramène
certaines fouilles mais peut-être pas
autant qu'ils le souhaitent alors vous
nous disiez tout à l'heure attention aux
critiques du Conseil consuel notamment
venu de juris ou dites attention danger
qu'est-ce que vous répondez à ça le
Conseil constitutionnel en effet a
toujours été critiqué j'ai toujours
connu ça et les politiques le critique
parce qu'ils ne sont pas contents de sa
décision et puis ça change de quand en
fonction des années bon ça c'est
évidemment c'est moi j'ai toujours connu
ça moi je ne me situe pas du tout dans
cette perspective là c'est pas du tout
une critique politicienne que que je
fais d'ailleurs lorsque j'ai rédigé mon
ouvrage il n'était pas destiné à être
d'actualité originellement donc c'est un
travail de fond et précisément moi je
crois que il y a un danger qui est tout
aussi grand à décrédibiliser les
institutions
qui ne sont pas enfin à crédibiliser
plutôt d'ailleurs les institutions qui
ne sont pas du tout vertueuses
et qui justement ne respecte pas les
principes démocratiques
constitutionnel dans cette dans cette
catégorie
tous les critères faisant que un juge
est un juge dans un état de droit
démocratique un juge légitime et le
conseil ne remplit quasi aucun de ces
critères alors ces critères là je les ai
pas inventés je les ai pris dans les
institutions internationales dans la
doctrine et la justice constitutionnelle
et bien pour être considérée comme
justice constitutionnelle légitime au
sens elle va opposer une parole à un
pouvoir politique souvent élu
démocratiquement donc elle doit remplir
des conditions pour le faire pour se
faire et le conseil ne les remplit pas
alors on a parlé de l'impartialité on
pourrait parler de la dépendance on
pourrait parler de la déontologie on
pourrait parler de ces décisions de la
manière dont elles sont argumentées il y
a un grand théoricien du droit belge qui
s'appelle Shine Perelman qui est mort
aujourd'hui mais qui est un spécialiste
de la justice et qui disait que les
décisions qui n'étaient pas argumentées
sont le signe des États autoritaires et
pas des États démocratiques mais les
décisions et je reviens moi j'essaye
d'être le plus simple possible dans ce
débat à l'addition du 14 avril pour vous
elle est pas argumentée en droit elle
est non elle est très peur argumentée en
droit quasiment pas alors je m'entends
qu'est-ce qu'une décision argumentée le
Conseil constitutionnel souvent dit la
loi est conforme ou n'est pas conforme
parce que la loi dit ce qu'elle dit mais
jamais il ne nous explique pourquoi ce
qu'elle dit est conforme ou n'est pas
conforme c'est rareissime qu'il le fasse
et de ce fait quelquefois il dit faut
aller voir d'autres décisions
antérieures mais quand on remonte le fil
quand on remonte la chaîne on trouve
jamais l'explication donc il faut
souvent se tenir pour dire que telle
question et bien est conforme ou et
contraire à la Constitution il suffit de
lire la loi où il suffit de lire la
Constitution il n'y a absolument aucune
argumentation
qu'on ne trouve pas véritablement non
plus
lorsque on ouvre les délibérations 25
ans après puisque pour le coup nous
sommes un des seuls pays qui a ouvert
une délibération d'une cour de justice
25 ans après et c'est honorable
simplement ça nous a permis de voir que
finalement le conseil ne faisait pas
véritablement bien son travail comme on
avait pu l'imaginer donc c'est un vrai
problème parce qu'en fait il ne permet
pas qu'il y ait une culture
constitutionnelle il ne permet pas une
appropriation démocratique de la
Constitution puisque précisément il n'en
dit quasiment rien ce qui contraste avec
les décisions de la couronnement de la
cour italien de la Cour européenne des
droits de l'homme ou même de la Cour
suprême des États-Unis qui je sais ne
sont pas un exemple en ce moment
le manque d'argumentation finalement
vous dites que c'est presque historique
vous avez siégé pendant 9 ans au Conseil
émotionnel il y avait un travail
juridique que vous faisiez
d'abord moi je n'ai connu que le
contrôle a priori de la loi qui est
quand même une particularité française
je crois qu'il y a la Roumanie le
Portugal enfin c'est quelque chose comme
disait Vedène professeur de droit et
membre du Conseil constitutionnel d'une
brutalité extrême c'est-à-dire on
demande à concours constitutionnel qui a
le dernier mot de statuer sur une loi
qui est l'expression d'une du programme
gouvernementale et c'était le cas pour
les retraites et de dire si elle est
conforme à la Constitution donc il y a
quand même une confrontation qui est
double qui est d'abord que on est des
réviseurs de la loi et deuxièmement on a
un mois pour statuer et donc
effectivement les c'est abstrait c'est
très abstrait c'est-à-dire c'est un
rituel on fixe des principes on cite la
loi et on dit la loi est conforme ou
elle est conforme sous réserve de donc
c'est quelque chose qui est très
abstrait qui est moins argumenté que
d'autres cours parce que les autres
cours ne statue pas sur l'abstral ne
statue pas sur des lois en tant que tel
elle statue sur des cas pratiques mais
je dois dire que le Conseil
constitutionnel à ma connaissance et la
juridiction la plus transparente au
monde d'une part les délibérée sont
publiés après 25 ans tiens-moi ce que
j'ai dit c'est publié après 25 ans ce
qui est quand même incroyable du point
de vue démocratique et je sais qu'il y a
certains membres qui ne disent plus rien
en séance parce qu'ils savent qu'ils
seront encore vivants quand on va
pouvoir lire leur délibéré et je trouve
c'est antidémocratique premièrement
Conseil d'État c'est 75 ans et les
autres les publier aussi vite c'est ce
que nous dites le délibéré c'est vous
ouvrez votre cœur vous dites ce que vous
pensez moi j'ai voté la plupart du temps
contre mes idées politiques par exemple
la réforme sur les 35 heures de Madame
Aubry qui nous annonçait que ça allait
rayer le chômage je n'y ai jamais cru
j'ai pas voté je voyais pas quelle
inconstitutionnalité en tous les cas en
98 il y avait dans la loi donc moi dans
la majorité des cas j'ai voté contre mes
idées politiques et d'autre part je
conteste absolument que il y ait pas de
travail quand on sait qu'une loi va être
déférée parce que les débats sont assez
chauds et bien on suit les travaux
parlementaires
depuis le début on lit tous les rapports
on lit les débats on toutes les
professeurs je veux dire moi j'ai
consulté énormément de professeurs de
drogue je vous ai pas consulté parce que
n'existait pas à l'époque mais enfin je
veux dire on ne sort pas du chapeau on a
un service juridique qui est très bien
fait mais c'est vrai que c'est un
contrôle abstrait qui ressemble beaucoup
d'ailleurs à la Cour de justice de
l'Union européenne de Luxembourg et ça
n'est pas aussi vivant que
un tribunal qui juge monsieur X ou
Madame Y dans une situation concrète et
en réalité c'est quand même motivé et
c'est motivé aux arguments à aligner à
notre mature du 14 avril elle était une
certaine manière pas fondée en droit
parce que pas assez argumenté et je
repense à l'utilisation moi de de ce
fameux véhicule il est juste là-dessus
de mémoire je suis pas du tout
constitutionnalisme mais j'ai cru dire
que le Conseil constitutionnel jugeait
que le recours à ces différents
outils constitutionnels étaient au moins
inédit ou inhabituel enfin il le
soulignait c'était essouillé mais qu'il
le jugeait comme c'était dans la
solution conforme à la Constitution
est-ce qu'à l'inverse s'il avait dit non
c'est anticonstitutionnel pour cette
raison là il aurait pas pris une
décision politique mais dans tous les
cas en fait il prend une décision
politique déjà parce qu'elle a un impact
politique
ce qui se passe c'est que il alors je
tiens à préciser que
ces décisions en vertu de la
Constitution fond droit il n'y a pas de
difficulté là-dessus ces décisions font
droit il s'agit pas de les contester
mais je distingue entre l'idée que ces
décisions font droit et l'idée qu'il
fait du droit je reprends l'argument
d'un ancien membre du Conseil
constitutionnel Olivier du Teillet de
Lamotte qui disait que le Conseil
constitutionnel vivait dans un climat de
pauvreté intellectuelle ce n'est pas moi
qui le dis c'est lui bon lorsqu'on dit
la décision
on peut avoir le sentiment qu'en effet
il ne fait pas de politique en disant
que le véhicule est inhabituel mais
qu'il est dans la Constitution et que
donc ça va oui sauf que ça c'est
éminemment politique de dire cela
pourquoi parce que une constitution ça
n'est pas un réservoir d'outils et
d'armes dont on peut se servir à sa
guise ça n'a jamais été ça l'idée
constitutionnelle les révolutionnaires
et avant eux les révolutions les
révolutions français avant eux les
révolutionnaires Américains et les
révolutionnaires anglais ont tous voulu
fixer des limites à l'exercice du
pouvoir pour remplir certaines finalités
et une règle de droit depuis le temps
des temps c'est un rapport entre des
moyens et des finalités si on dette
déconnecte les moyens des finalités on
ne fait plus de droit et le Conseil
constitutionnel non seulement fait ça
mais en plus il ne dit pas pourquoi il
dit c'est inhabituel mais c'est
constitutionnel mais il ne dit pas
pourquoi
est-ce que cette décision là mais d'une
manière générale l'édition du conseil
sont suffisamment argumenter endroit
conçu mais je n'irai pas sur ce terrain
là moi ce qui me semble important c'est
de bien replacer le sens des
responsabilités c'est-à-dire qu'il
faudrait pas qu'un débat politique sur
l'âge de la retraite et une réforme
systémique de la retraite se déplace sur
un débat purement actionnaire sur des
procédures et là on voit un danger quand
même je trouve dans pas droit mais dans
l'opinion
la responsabilité d'une réforme des
relate elle est éminemment politique et
d'ailleurs si on fait la comparaison
avec la Cour suprême des États-Unis moi
ce qui est ce qui m'a toujours choqué
dans ce système qui est très différent
d'une autre c'est qu'au fond la Cour
suprême américaine elle prend des
décisions très politiques et sur des
sujets éminemment important sur le droit
à l'avortement sur le droit de porter
des armes et ça et moi je considère là
que on a une forme de dérive de la démoc
c'est débat là ils doivent être tranchés
par le peuple par ses représentants ou
par ou directement par le référendum
donc moi je vois quand même un danger à
vouloir faire dériver finalement le sens
des responsabilités et la personne ou la
nation qui doit assumer cette décision
alors c'est intéressant parce que juste
avant la décision du Conseil
constitutionnel on avait des instituts
de sondage on va regarder un baromètre
d'oxa qui était publié pour le Figaro là
là aussi la veille de la de la décision
question posée
aux Français faites-vous confiance au
Conseil constitutionnel pour rendre des
décisions impartiales c'est très partagé
oui 48%, non 51% je voudrais que il nous
reste ça file vite le temps à moins de
moins de 10 minutes dans ce débat poser
la question de la perception du Conseil
par les Français peut-être des moyens de
rapprocher les Français de cette haute
juridiction et je propose à Mathias ça
reste de nous rejoindre parce que on va
parler de la
QPC la question prioritaire de
constitutionnalité Mathias
donc là on est dans le cas d'un Conseil
constitutionnel qui intervient à la
demande des citoyens voilà c'est ça
c'est l'essentiel de son travail 80% des
décisions rendues aujourd'hui par le
Conseil constitutionnel sont donc des
QPC question prioritaire de
constitutionnalités mécanisme entrée en
vigueur en mars 2010 suite à la révision
constitutionnelle de 2008 voulue par
Nicolas Sarkozy alors le principe en
résumé est assez simple tout juste
iciable devant n'importe quel
juridiction peut saisir le Conseil
constitutionnel s'il estime que la loi
que l'on voudrait lui appliquer et
contraire aux libertés fondamentales
garantie par la Constitution alors
toutefois de précision 1 j'ai bien dit
justiciable cela implique donc il est un
procès et par la même qu'il n'y a pas de
condition de nationalité de une QPC ne
peut être posée qu'à posteriori de la
première question de la loi et au cours
de la procédure judiciaire les questions
préalables elles sont elles réservées
aux politiques alors on va se poser la
question son utilisation est-ce que
disposition cette QPC est très souvent
utilisée alors ça dépend comment on voit
les choses le 25 avril 2022 le conseil
de la rue de Montpensier enregistré sa
millième saisine en 12 ans il y a eu un
petit pic au début c'est l'effet de
nouveautés avec on le voit 124 questions
en 2011 et puis une stabilisation autour
de 75 questions par an un chiffre qui
reste trop faible pour le président des
sages Laurent Fabius c'était sur notre
antenne à l'occasion des 10 ans de la
QPC les Français se rayent pas tous les
matins avant de regarder votre chaîne en
disant qu'est-ce que je vais faire avec
le Conseil constitutionnel bon mais il
faut donc informer et ce que nous
faisons aujourd'hui à l'occasion de ces
10 ans de la QPC c'est grâce à vous
notamment de développer l'information et
la formation à la fois des citoyens en
général et des professionnels du droit
c'est comme ça qu'on arrivera petit à
petit et j'espère assez rapidement à ce
que on se saisisse de plus en plus de la
Qc
très années d'existence aujourd'hui pour
cette ces questions au prédateurs de
constitutionnalité est-ce qu'il y a eu
des décisions plus notables que les
autres alors ce sera à vous d'en décider
moi j'en ai sélectionné trois la
première la cristallisation des pensions
en 2010 alors le Conseil constitutionnel
a estimé que le régime spécial des
pensions à applicables ressortissants
d'anciennes colonies françaises
provoquait une rupture d'égalité avec
les Français retraités dans ces mêmes
anciennes colonies là donc censuré
certaines dispositions législatives
relatives à ce régime il y a également
eu la radiation automatique des listes
électorales des candidats ayant commis
certaines infractions les Sages ont
censuré l'article 7 du code électoral le
11 juin 2010 au motif que cette
automaticité de peine était contraire au
principe d'individualisation des peines
enfin l'une des plus emblématiques on se
souvient tous de la condamnation de
Cédric Hérault pour délit de solidarité
une décision qui avait été finalement
cassée par la Cour de cassation et bien
le militant promigrant avait posé
également une
QPC au Conseil constitutionnel
concernant son cas une démarche qui
avait débouchée sur une décision
historique la consécration du principe
de fraternité un délibéré mettant fin
ensuite au délit de solidarité dans un
but humanitaire merci Mathias 80% des
décisions du Conseil consuel lié à des
QPC Noël Lenoir et pourtant je suis sûr
que beaucoup de Français ne connaissent
pas cette cette procédure vous y voyez
un progrès moi j'y vois un progrès
considérable parce que ça permet de
vider de leur venin des lois qui sont
encore en vigueur qu'on ne va pas
réformer et ça pose de manière beaucoup
plus directe la question des droits
fondamentaux le Conseil constitutionnel
qui devrait s'appeler cours
constitutionnel a pour mission première
de protéger et je trouve que c'est un
véritable progrès que François
Mitterrand avait promu et en 91 ça avait
été adopté à l'Assemblée mais pas au
Sénat et donc maintenant c'est rentrer
dans les mœurs c'est je trouve c'est
très bien je suis pas sûr que augmenter
considérablement le nombre de QPC soit
un but quand on regarde la Cour suprême
des États-Unis elle statut dans 94 ans
donc c'est quand même beaucoup si
précisément on veut aller au fond et si
on veut avoir le temps de prendre des
délibérations qui sont comprises par le
grand public mais enfin même si vous
lisez un arrêt d'une cour d'appel en
France c'est pas fait pour le grand
public donc le droit c'est quand même un
peu complexe
ou pas alors encore une fois je fais la
distinction entre la mission
et l'organe qui exerce cette mission
donc la mission le fait qu'on puisse
poser la question de la
constitutionnalité d'une loi à
l'occasion d'un procès en soi c'est une
bonne chose mais la problématique c'est
quand on regarde celui qui est chargé
d'exercer cette mission alors quand même
je me permets de signaler parce que je
crois que c'est une information
importante c'est que
[Musique]
secrétaire d'État je peux citer le fait
que les personnes qui étaient
incriminées dans la faire EADS ou aussi
bénéficier d'une QPC qui a réussi et
donc leur poursuites ont été abandonnées
donc il y a beaucoup de choses comme ça
faisant que on peut pas lire cette QPC
de manière tout à fait homogène comme
une grande victoire des droits et
libertés individuels et collectifs des
citoyens avec le noir c'est c'est un
moyen de rapprocher les citoyens de du
Conseil conditionnel malgré tout oui oui
moi je crois que c'est très positif
après la façon dont cette procédure est
utilisée par les citoyens les
associations et encore très perfectible
à l'évidence moi j'ai souvenir d'une QPC
qui avait été faite pour abroger le
Concordat puisque le Concordat existe
encore dans 3 départements français la
réponse avait été négative du Conseil
conditionnel et dans les indiscrétions
que j'avais pu recueillir du président
de l'époque
l'argument avait été dire qu'au fond
cette question était moins une question
concessionnelle une question politique
et que si demain le législateur le
Parlement vous les remettre mettre en
cause le Concordat et bien il pouvait le
faire mais il fallait pas faire porter
au juge conditionnel la responsabilité
d'une réforme politique majeure merci
beaucoup merci à tous d'avoir participé
à ce débat qui était passionnant je vais
rappeler à Lauréline fontaine le titre
de votre livre la Constitution
maltraitée anatomie du Conseil
constitutionnel qui est publié aux
éditions Amsterdam je rappellerai de
côté que vous êtes expert associé à la
Fondation Jean Jaurès et Noël Lenoir
merci beaucoup d'être venu partager avec
nous votre expertise et votre expérience
d'anciens membres du Conseil
constitutionnel Mathieu je vous dis
on est quel jour on est mercredi donc à
la semaine prochaine à lundi merci à
tous de votre fidélité à sens unique
vous pouvez retrouver l'émission et
toutes les émissions de la chaîne sur
notre plateforme Public Sénat point fr